you know this is my first time ever
taking yoga because this is my first
time being in a minimum security prison
any other time i go to maximum security
prisons well we just in this [ __ ]
thugging
you know but it's structured
you know our prison is structured
and
that's the first time i had ever like
experimented with yoga
and i liked it
at first though i was like i ain't bout
to do no yoga that's some old [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah for sure yeah yeah [ __ ] you go
do the yoga right my cellar kept on
telling me man i'm telling you man you
just gotta do it he's not in t-bone man
shout out to t-bone
yeah
so yoga i mean yeah that is interesting
that would have used the tim come on
papa we gotta go do yoga come on he's
man they got yoga and i'm like my ain't
about to go do no yoga man i'm telling
you he couldn't even he was having knee
problems he started doing yoga now he's
he don't even he's not even in pain
anymore come on you got to go
something like uh yeah but just
one day i went i gave it a try for the
first time i said man this bitch-ass
[ __ ]
man the first maybe the first two poses
i got into
i immediately had to go to the bathroom
and [ __ ]
wow and it just yoga started curving my
appetite and things of that nature but
when i came home upon being reinserted
back into society i kind of like got
away from those things
but then when i got back into fitness
i was like you back on the yoga yeah i
do yoga every day what are the benefits
for somebody for someone who says the
same thing you said this is some [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] hey i know it's gonna sound
crazy
but when i meet people that do yoga i'd
be like you're a gangster
cause i know
it's been a journey for me
and the beautiful thing is yoga is
non-judging
it's just you being one with yourself
it's non-judging it's just you focus on
yourself you focus on your breathing
and every breath you try to deepen the
stretch
and it's very very it's therapeutic
it's like you get a hive from it wow and
you release like one time i was doing a
pigeon pose
that's where you had your leg like a
little ear and your other leg that's
when you open your hip
and
i was opening my hip flexor
and
when i was in the stretch i just started
crying
she started crying tears
and later she just put her hands on my
back
and she said the energy that you're
feeling is not your own
you're having a release
you're having an emotional detox she
said this is
psychic debris that you're picking up on
just release the things that no longer
serve you
she said no
say it say i release all of the things
that no longer serve me
i said it
and then my new yoga coach
i was telling her that my left hip not
as flexible as my right heel
and she was like well
you know your left side of your body is
feminine your right side is masculine
so you should ask your hip what is it
that you're trying to teach me
so like i talked to my body parts now
because
once i start saying what is it that
you're trying to teach me or what is it
that you need me to release
things started changing in my life
like it's crazy like when we get rid of
baggage
like our bodies
are lighter
it's just
the things around us weigh us down
they're anchors
that could be people too right it could
be worse yeah that's really one of the
biggest things
so
when i every time i do my stretch nah my
pitching pose on the left side i always
tell my hip thank you
like thank you for trusting me thank you
for releasing thank you for teaching me
thank you for serving me
i thank my feet thank you for all the
stability you give me because i'm out
you're stepping on these i'm just
i mean you do have a song you do have a
song in the album called stepping
great record by the way
i do want to be funny